chapter 18
is on an extension of least squares to
non-linear least squares we'll explain
that momentarily it's a very interesting
topic
so we'll start with the idea of
nonlinear equations and
non-linear least squares so
a set of nonlinear equations look
something like this
i have some variables uh x1 through xn
and those are scalar variables and i
think of them all together as simply a
vector x and then i have a set of
equations like
f i of these variables is equal to 0 and
i have
m of those this is like a if f is
affined
this becomes a set of linear equations
um
so we refer to f i of x equals 0 as the
ith equation
and if i commit if i choose an x then f
i of x is the
residual residual is usually something
like an error
or it's it's an amount by which
something fails to hold and in this case
if f i of x is you know with the
residual
it tells you if it's a zero that means
that equation holds if it's you know
.003 that means it almost holds and if
it's minus point zero zero zero one it
means it also almost holds
okay um so we can write
this set of the system of equations up
here in a very compact format just as f
of x equals zero
um and here f is a function that maps
r n to r m and that what that means is
it takes in an n vector
or n or n scale scalar arguments x one
through x xn
and it returns an m vector
and these are the residuals the m
residuals so
and sometimes you can write it this way
it's f of x equals f1 of x
up to fm of x now
if f is affined the system of equations
f of x
equals zero is just a set of linear
equations and we'll refer to this set of
linear equations uh sorry
nonlinear equations um following
the uh following the nomenclature we use
for linear equations we're going to
refer to these as
over determined if there is more if
there are more
equations than variables it's going to
be underdetermined if there are fewer
variables
m than um sorry if there's fewer
equations than variables so m is the
number of equations n is the number of
variables
and square if they're exactly equal so
we're going to follow the
the same nomenclature we use for systems
of linear equations
nonlinear least squares is the following
problem
it's find find a vector x
hat that minimizes the following simply
norm f
x squared and that's f 1 of x squared
plus it's basically the sum of the
squares of the residuals
in an equation okay um now this
includes the the problem of solving uh
the equation simply the nonlinear
equations f of x equals zero that's a
special case
um because if there is an
x for which f of x equals zero then for
sure that
x is is uh solves
minimizes this because then the norm
squared is zero
and norm squared don't come any smaller
than zero so that means that
no other point x uh could beat it okay
so
so this is just a special case um um but
like linear least squares
uh it's super useful on its own in other
words even when
there is no x for which f of x equals
zero this finds you something
that kind of gives you a nice compromise
that minimizes the sum of the squares of
the residuals
so very similar to linear least squares
but this is the non-linear least squares
problem and so we have these
these functions and the goal is simply
to minimize
the basically the norm squared of f of x
where f of x is this mapping from rn to
rm
so let's look at the optimality
condition uh and we'll get that from
uh calculus um and there'll be a few
things i'm gonna say about that
um so the first is uh that the gradient
of the uh one you know calculus tells us
that
if i have a function of many variables
um
it if a point x is optimal then
the gradient vanishes at that point
um by the way if that weren't the case
you could just step in any dir in you
know in one of the directions in order a
very small amount
along one of the uh along one of the
axes to actually find a point that has
slightly smaller uh object objective
value in this case the norm squared of f
of x
now also you should remember that there
are points where the gradient vanishes
but they don't minimize the function for
example they could maximize the function
okay so as i said you know points can
satisfy this and not be
optimal i think one way to say points
that satisfy this are sometimes called
stationary because you know that's what
it means
stationary means that if you move a
little bit in any direction
the function doesn't decrease uh uh
fast right it might decrease a very very
small amount but that's that's
stationary
um and the gradient of the norm squared
of f of x
um we can write this out and by the way
this is a formula completely analogous
to what you'd see in the scalar case
i'm not going to drive it here you
you'll find that in the book to see how
that's derived
but it turns out that this thing is
exactly
2 times df of x hat
transpose times f of x equals zero okay
so that is the condition and you know
look that would be the same if i
if f were a scalar function and i said
what
what's the condition that this is
minimized well we'd take the gradient of
this thing or
well in this case just the derivative
and we'd get 2
f prime of x times
f of x here is what we'd get and that
would be
we'd want that to be 0 if that's
minimized
now in the scalar case it's it's pretty
simple
um it's either f of x is it's either f
of x is
zero or f prime of x is zero and this
kind of makes sense
um okay so this is the matrix
analog of this scalar equation here
um right of course you don't see
transposes here because these are just
scalars
all right now this matrix df of x
df evaluated x hat that's the derivative
or jacobian matrix
of the function f and that's simply the
matrix of partial derivatives so
the i j entry is the partial derivative
of f
i uh with respect to the variable x j
and all evaluated at x hat okay now
this condition if f
is affine then this
condition is reduces exactly to the
normal equations you see
in in normal uh in in linear least
squares so-called linear least squares
oh i should say that when we're talking
about non-linear least squares
we refer to least squares as linear
least squares
to to help distinguish
now we get to uh an admission so here's
the admission
it turns out solving nonlinear equations
is like
basically super hard um so in other
words
simply you know if i give you uh even
things with you know as few as 10 or 20
variables
and it turns out it's just insanely
difficult to actually minimize
the norm squared of f of x
so in particular it's much harder
than solving linear equations we can
solve linear equations with
easily with thousands of variables
thousands of equations
no problem and we will always get
exactly the solution
period um that's least squares and we'll
get it by the way super fast
nonlinear non-linear equations not
linearly squared is a different story
and in fact the following is even hard
if i give you
a non-linear function f and i simply say
does there exist a solution so just find
me
find me an x for which f of x equals
zero
even that problem is hard now
um when i say it's it's hard and what i
am is i'm i'm actually
i'm just interpreting what it means to
solve a problem it means find a point
where the norm squared is smaller than
any other point
that is actually hard to do but we turns
out there's still methods
that do very well in a practical sense
and we'll use so-called heuristic
algorithms now a heuristic algorithm
is one that is it's not always
guaranteed to work
work in the sense of actually finding
the actual point that minimizes
but they often work very well in
practice by the way even when they fail
to find a point that truly minimizes
the objective function they can find a
point that is quite good
and the truth is often they do actually
solve the problem
but we've encountered this before so
the k-means algorithm is that is
a that is a heuristic for solving the
quadratic clustering problem
and what that means is that the k means
algorithm
when you run it it is absolutely not
guaranteed to find the point that
minimizes the objective in the k-means
problem
okay so and we even saw that that was
the case because we'd run k-means a
couple of times
and we would indeed find that sometimes
it it finds
you know a point with one value and then
later it finds a point with a lower
value meaning that
in the first case that was not optimal
period it's also likely that the one you
found later wasn't optimal
so um nevertheless heuristics like this
still work
very very well in practice right hasn't
hasn't stopped the use of k-means
k-means is used all over the world
in hundreds of applications and areas
all the time and it works just fine
thank you in a practical sense right so
the only thing i would say about that is
if someone says have you really
minimized that
you know and if you're in a court of law
or there's i don't know mathematicians
hanging around or something like that
then your answer would have to be okay
no
technically i don't know that i've
actually minimized it but boy that's a
pretty good
you know that's pretty good clustering
wouldn't you say so
so that's the same idea with um it's
exactly the same for non-linear
equations right that generally
generally we just use a heuristic and
the only thing that happens there is you
can't
you can't say that for sure that is
actually the point
that minimizes the norm squared of
f of x
we're now going to look at a couple of
examples uh just to see
uh what what do non-linear least squares
uh equations
i'm sorry look like what what what what
are some nonlinear equations you might
want to solve and so on
um and by the way later we'll tell you
we'll describe these heuristic
methods for solving the
nonlinear least squares problem which
includes a special case solving
non-linear least squares
but let's right now look just at some
examples
okay here's one is computing equilibrium
points
this comes up in a ton of fields all
over all over it comes up
and the general setting is that you've
got a bunch of variables
n of them and then usually what you have
is some kind of equilibrium
condition and the equilibrium condition
generally speaking means that
you know sort of consumption matches uh
consumption matches production i mean it
and it can depend what it is so these
are these are called
you know that's generally an equilibrium
an equilibrium point is when that
happens
um so i'll look at two examples uh
one from economics uh one from uh
chemistry so
in economics you look at uh you have the
idea of equilibrium prices and so
what that is is this is i have a
function s
and what it does is as a we we vary the
prices of
n goods that's the vector p um
s p tells you what will be the supply
of those goods if uh the prices are
p right and so you know that this is
kind of it's kind of clear intuitively
how that might work
um that for example as you
increase the the price uh if you
increase the price of some good
then more people are going to
manufacture it or supply it and so the
supply will go
up that's roughly the idea um
we also have the demand um the demand
will kind of go the other way
right that if i have if i have a demand
function and i increase the supply
of a good presumably its demand will go
down
now we've already seen in the price
elasticity matrix the idea that when you
put one when you when you increase one
price
um it could easily be uh
that uh that the demand for other things
uh other goods can either go up or go
down right so depending on whether it's
a substitute or something or a
correlator
i forget what they call it okay all
right so back to our problem
uh these are our functions the supply
function and the demand function
and here's the goal find a set of prices
for which the supply balances the demand
that's the idea okay so this is a very
classic problem
and what we'll do is we'll take f p to
be s of p
minus d of p that's the i think some
people call that the excess supply or
something
i don't remember anyway when that's when
f of p is zero
that means that the prices are such that
the supply
exactly balances the demand okay so
that's the that's called an
equilibrium price a set sorry a set of
equilibrium prices it's an equilibrium
price
vector okay so that's one example of
solving nonlinear equations um oh
i should add something uh that if uh if
the supply and demand functions are both
affine this is a set of linear equations
and we can solve it
yeah well well we solve it exactly in
that case using the methods previously
in the course
okay next example um
which although on the face of it looks
radically different it's actually kind
of the same example but
here it is um so in chemical equilibrium
what i have
uh is i have a bunch i have an n vector
of concentrations c
of n different uh species
right so these could species in in some
chemical solution let's say
um then what i have is this is i have uh
if i have various reactions that both
some reactions consume
the species others generate uh
additional species right so these are
the reactants and products
and they are given by reaction rates and
those are given this way
so capital c of little c that that tells
you the consumption
of the species as a function of the
concentrations so that's that's how that
works
so you know usually if the concentration
of a reactant goes up then
it's it's gonna it's it's gonna consume
more more of it will be consumed because
there's a
there's a reaction that that that
consumes it or something like that um
now we also have gfc
that's the generation of species these
are essentially the reactant products
so that says that as a function of the
concentrations
this tells you the rate at which the
species are
uh created right and that means that
there are
that that means what's the rate at which
the reaction in which
uh these things are on the right-hand
side uh they are products not reactants
okay so that's the idea and then
then what we'll do is we'll take what we
do would like to do is find the
concentrations
of these species in this solution or
whatever it is so that the consumption
is exactly
equal to the generation and what that
means is that the reactants
reactants products are balanced you may
still have you will have
chemical reactions going on but what
will happen is at
equilibrium uh the amount of you know
whatever
some hydrogen ion being consumed per
second
is going to exactly balance the amount
of hydrogen ion being
generated uh as a product uh every
second
you know due to multiple reactions so
that's the idea that that's that's
referred to as a chemical
equilibrium and you can you know you can
check how does that vary with
external things that we're not counting
here like temperature or something like
that pressure okay
so and to do that we'll set that up as f
c
is equal to uh the consumption minus the
generation
and so when f c is zero that means you
have chemical
equilibrium so that's the idea so these
are just computing equilibrium points
are generally non-linear
equations systems of nonlinear equations
and by the way very typically
with an equal number of with m and n
equal to each other so these are square
typically square
systems another example
uh well it comes it comes up in a lot of
areas but it's it's it's really part of
gps global positioning system so here
i have a three vector x and that's a
position in three dimensions and our
your job is to estimate it like
what is x and what we have is actually
so-called range measurements so of
course i'll draw on 2d but here's
x and you might have a a beacon
or something like that um or satellite
whatever you like
it's here and then what we measure is
actually the distance
so we measure the distance right so
here's a1 and here's a2
this point and so what we know is the
distance
now then the question is given a set of
distances
oh and i should say we get the distance
but with a noise
so vi is a little is a noise that we uh
we don't know
and it's just measurement error okay and
so
the idea is from these distance
measurements they're called range
measurements right because the range is
like the distance from u to some target
or from u
to some beacon or something like that
so given these noisy range measurements
your job is to figure out
what x is okay now
what least squares at least where's
location estimation does is it says
i these things here are essentially uh
this is it's going to sum them
we're going to minimize the sum of vi
squared okay
and this is just so this is b the uh so
what we're going to do here is we're
going to choose
x to minimize this row i is the measured
range or distance and this is
of course a function of x um it is
definitely not
affine um and we'll want to minimize
this and that is
that is a set that is a non-linear least
squares uh
that's non-linear least squares right
and a variation on this actually is
kind of what's used in gps the global
positioning system um
there there is one a couple of uh tricks
in gps or variations on this this that
are not in
my formulation here um one is this
is that in addition um when you get your
distance to a satellite there's an
additional offset term which depends on
your uh your how how far your clock is
from the true clock right so unless you
happen to have an atomic clock with you
very few people do so there's an
additional variable there but otherwise
it's basically
this and in fact this is kind of what's
used for gps
actually really what's used for g is
it's a combination of this
and the kalman filtering or state
estimation that we looked at
in the previous lecture but this is the
essential idea